the Federal Reserve is expected to raise
interest rates by another three quarters
of a percentage point today Regulators
are trying to bring down the worst
inflation we've seen in 40 years but
that policy change has pushed mortgage
rates above seven percent as Nancy Chen
shows us the rising cost of borrowing is
hurting home buyers and sellers
you want one more treat for about a year
Andrew till tried to sell his New Jersey
home in search of more space so we've
had a lot of activity and a lot of
offers on the house when we had it on
the market it's like every weekend our
broker calling and saying can you get
out but even after 10 lucrative offers
he and his family took it off the market
he says there are a few options for them
to buy a new house especially after
refinancing their mortgage in March to
below 3 percent you've been looking to
sell why haven't you our interest rate
right now that we have locked in is very
low so our borrowing costs would more
than double with today's rate a monthly
mortgage payment on a 400 thousand
dollar home would cost you about seven
hundred and fifty dollars more than the
start of the year how would you describe
the housing market right now
so I would describe the housing market
as sort of a tug of war between buyer
and seller and that tug of war is almost
creating like a shutdown Stacey Esser is
a realtor in the New Jersey area it's
not that we've never seen seven percent
interest rate is that we've never seen
interest rates in basically one year go
from Two and a half percent to seven
percent Esser says this kind of
volatility is causing deals to fall
through a buyer might have a
pre-approval at a certain rate get an
accepted bid and then the interest rates
shift they didn't lock in and all of a
sudden they can't afford that same house
about sixty thousand deals have been
canceled so far this year the highest
share on record since the start of the
pandemic and new listings are down about
19 from a year ago what is the end game
to all this I think we're going to see
way less transactions than 2023 I think
people are going to be sitting on the
sidelines until things settle down till
says he'll wait until then we just
wanted to see if we could you know
strike while the iron was hot it didn't
happen and we're happy here
the housing market is a leading
indicator of whether the nation is
heading into a recession but here's the
thing it could also contribute to one
fewer homes being purchased also means
less construction as well as people
buying fewer items like appliances and
all of this could have huge Ripple
effects throughout the economy yeah I
haven't played tug of war since I was a
kid it'll be interesting to see who wins
in this one the buyer or the seller or
we could all potentially end up losing
yeah yeah I forgot about that Nancy I
remember that too thank you Nancy good
to see you